hello all and welcome to this video
playing el trompo after the Trump offski
know at them hello maybe trompo is
really some someone I'm Spanish good
okay that's not one of the more exciting
openings the willow pass four nights
it's quite funny that sometimes the
positions actually at the end look a
little bit like in terms of Indian sorry
my watch was really still cannot shake
him after my cold oh wow that's
sophisticated oh okay I thought you
would maybe try for some f4 but yeah for
after he had provoked the weakness age 6
slide weakness yep try to make some
pressure on e4 and see if he wants to do
something with the center okay now i
have the queenside completely blocked
and this is what i was talking about
resembling the news oh this could if you
played in that I'm taking this on mmm
now you can take on age 6 or sorry on
age 60 b6 for some kind of desperado
desperado this is the song right
anyway I'm trying to play at five and
ignore the whole thing yay could place
takes on age 60 b6 but this is the right
plan with their five opening up some
leaflets and files my dream ending is
not against bishop and I'm trying to go
for that Nigeria brooke SF warm maybe
even with this sometimes root g 5o Luke
h5 might be possible ok so rock g5 maybe
I can be can provoke a little bit him
Bishop d to know but now Queen g4 is
good right just threatening checkmate
and if he takes rook takes I'm winning
the sea for porn that's nice I really
like that game when he was very
cooperative strategically but it's just
very nice to see how this finally drops
on yeah I take that he's got this egg
it's got c5 yeah if I go rook c4 he will
take one of the points because he's
close to promotion
yeah what's what's the best here yeah
probably this one then okay 86 I can
just take he cannot recaptured you to
Roxy one
yeah what's quickest here and how many
parts is that for got three parts that's
nice
yeah night she too doesn't do that much
go pin and take the a pawn as well
okay so
there's no particular need to give one
of the pawns up at the moment so I'm I'm
just keeping them still on how would you
do it
probably have to give one of the pawns
up ultimately but it's not necessary
just yet check okay Jim he can push me
back but still pinche shouldn't be
shouldn't be an issue
the sea pawn will ultimately win I guess
check white verisign it was just a bit
too too many pawns um yeah he was just
very very cooperative with all the
exchanges for example right here taking
on d 7 hmm i don't know i think this is
rather helpful for me and I thought
Bishop c4 but I think he should think
about defaults already something i'm a
bit critical off because you're just
weakening your pawn structure here yeah
this is now weakened all those and jim i
mean probably maybe you should take only
five now and try to simplify down after
the five I'm I'm a lot better yeah I've
got stock fishy and its top which hugely
underestimates the white provides
problems here what's whitey has
strategically huge problems and stop
which just gives black 0.2 which is by
far by far under estimating the danger
there are many endings that are just
losing him and yeah okay and i get f
five and i'm absolutely sure to to do
that Oh came here I can take you for of
course but I didn't want to yeah I
didn't want to calculate this kind of
stuff when I'm goes to cheated you just
a better game this yeah I know f5 comes
and now stock fish stock fishes
evaluation goes down with that wasn't
available anyway he will get a
five-episode just treat this stuff check
and now stop Fisher's on- to wear yeah
you cannot cannot defend against all
others yeah night h4 is a winning attack
already
yeah that's possible but I was just I
just like this so much that I will win
this win this pawn here with the rook
yeah c5 this may be relatively best
after which book c4 comes can just take
and just take everything I mean I didn't
play that well technically he I should
have played this actually to make d6
impossible that would have been a lot
easier Edric ending while being
completely winning I was still taking
quite a while but it's just too many
points I mean you can save many rook
endings but not with free porns down
yeah White's problem is he under or was
here he underestimated the problems of
his pawn structure i mean this self also
gave me some time but if he just stays
put here Ken or does this media to put
the pawns on light squared Bishop on
dark squares nothing much should happen
but the way you played it it was very
very nice for me ok thanks for watching